they are the enemy of the people and we
could have a country that would be able
to heal and get together except the
media foments it they're so corrupt and
you know i called it i came up with the
term fake news a long time ago i don't
know if i'll get credit for that but
that's okay well you won't get credit
for it because you didn't come up with
the term what and it now this is this is
super interesting the term fake news has
been around a really really long time
and it has a specific meaning like the
original fake news was
hillary clinton birthing an alien baby
or something like i'm not saying that's
the first fake news story but it
referred to like tabloid
fake news
later in the advent during the after the
advent of online news
fake news was used to refer to the same
type of stuff but online just totally
made up stories trump didn't invent the
term fake news what trump pioneered was
calling any reporting you don't like
fake news that's trump's contribution
it's a very negative contribution